[Music]
Miami their state lawmakers in Utah just
passed a new law to try to make
trampoline parks safer Utah joins at
least seven other states requiring more
oversight from insurance companies and
annual inspections the popular theme
parks have exploded into a billion
dollar industry in the last eight years
alone the number of trampoline parks as
here's a pun jumped the total increase
from around 40 locations in the u.s. to
more than a thousand around the world
but in this country they all operate
without any federal oversight meg Oliver
has been looking into the rise in
injuries at this part at these parks Meg
good morning good morning to all of you
just days before that Utah law was
signed a high school football player was
paralyzed after being injured at a
trampoline park in that state in the
last seven years CBS News has confirmed
at least six people have died from
injuries at trampoline parks that number
could be even higher because many of
those injured are often forced into
arbitration and signed confidentiality
agreements that stop from them from
speaking out on most weekends trampoline
parks are packed with hundreds of kids
bouncing jumping into pits and playing
tag their popularity is leading to new
cases for attorneys like David chasin he
represents more than a dozen people
injured at trampoline parks in New
Jersey look below the screen there at
the bottom right of the screen a father
unknowingly causes what's known as a
double bounce his four year-old son
falls to the mat the force of the
trampoline coming back up from the
father's hop across broke the
four-year-olds femur oh my gosh it takes
almost a full minute before anyone
including the guard on duty realizes the
child is squirming in pain that bear
Don Macpherson has coached gymnastics
for more than 40 years since 2011 he's
been an expert witness in more than 200
plaintiff cases against trampoline parks
he says the injuries they can cause our
life altering broken necks broken backs
dislocated and open fractured elbows
shoulders
these are injuries that this is seem
like military-grade they're all
catastrophic injuries McPherson says the
danger lies in the design several
trampolines are connected with steel
cables or chain links under thin padding
as people jump waves of energy are
generated in all directions which can
cause those double bounces that can end
in high-impact collisions they're moving
at speeds and with energy that when they
hit or get hit by somebody else that's
twice their weight they end up with
crush injuries injuries so severe they
can lead to death at his peak Rick's
wheezy was a world-class gymnast other
than his children and me that mattered
most in his life was his gymnastics that
all changed in 2017 when Rick visited a
trampoline park in Virginia with his
husband Nick scammed alias and their
twins
Nick says Rick was jumping on the
trampoline when he came down wrong in
his foot stumbled and hit his head
against a thinly padded wall the c2
vertebra cracked constricted his airway
and his blood flow paralyzed him he was
over 90% brain dead within three minutes
you lost the love of your life
yep
I watched the lights go out in his eyes
in the last few years emergency room
visits caused by trampoline park
injuries has skyrocketed according to
the Consumer Product Safety Commission
the numbers have shot up from 2,500 in
2013 to almost 18,000 in 2017 everybody
in the gymnastics community calls them
death Parks McPherson took us to a
trampoline park outside Chicago this
whole setup is wrong he pointed out
several red flags from lack of
supervision there's no one here and
trampolines flush against thinly padded
walls how dangerous is that dangerous
you'll get a brain bleed from hitting to
foam pits adjacent to trampolines that
McPherson says are too shallow they
probably have enough foam but it's the
design of their foam pits they're not
deep enough are you risking your life
when you go to these trampoline parks
yes unknowingly for families like Nick's
the message is simple never birthday
parties no never never never never you
believe they're that dangerous I don't
know how to believe any other way right
my husband was an elite-level
gymnast in response to the deaths and
injuries the International Association
of trampoline parks told us there are
parks that do not adhere to technical
industry standards and do not operate
with safety at the forefront of their
agendas the group will launch an
initiative this summer to require
third-party inspections to ensure the
safest experience possible the problem
with that is out of the 800 trampoline
parks in the US only 25% of them are
members how can you tell if the one in
your community is meeting standards you
would have to go and find out if they
are you know following these standards
but the problem is when you go into
these trampoline parks you see the signs
you're risking injury you're risking
death everything supervision because nor
I mean we had a trampoline in my
backyard and there had to be an adult
there watching to make sure at that park
that we went to outside Chicago there
was a guard over here a lot of kids
jumping over here you know they need
more supervision that's the big I know
it's fun but it's you know I'm a little
scared looking at your piece what
about people that like Anthony said have
trampolines at home that's so the
American Academy of pediatricians they
warned they advise against backyard
trampolines but the expert in our piece
said in the big picture he thinks those
are safer under adult supervision I also
talked to a trauma surgeon out in Utah
who said he can fix those broken wrists
from a backyard trampoline but the
injuries the open wound fractures coming
in from trampoline parks it's really
hard war zone injuries very important
story thank you very much meg